good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you come out so you can have a positive
impact on yourself on your family your
community and the world so to help you
on your journey today's message is
surround yourself with great people over
to you Warren Buffett you will move in
the direction of the people that you
associate with so I it's important to
associate with people that are better
than yourself and actually the most
important decision many of you make not
all of you will be the spouse you choose
and you really you want to associate
with people who are the kind of person
you'd like to be you'll move in that
direction and the most important person
by far in that respect is your spouse I
can't overemphasize how important that
is you're right
the friends you have they will form you
as you go through life and make some
good friends keep them for the rest of
your life but have them be people that
you admire as well as why come here this
is why I keep going with my youtube
channel this is the reason why I keep
going with my youtube channel because
yes your spouse is important and yes
your friend is important and the people
that you hang out with our super super
super important and all the other people
that you hang out with by reading books
and consuming content watching videos
all of that makes an impact to the more
that you spend hanging around people and
ideas and wisdom that bring you up the
more you're going to rise up and the
more you're around people who are
complaining and negative and pulling you
down guess what happens the more you're
gonna be pulled down and one of the big
reasons for me in creating this channel
was I wanted to be around successful
entrepreneurs I wanted to be around
people who would push me to go off and
do more because in my life I'm super
fortunate to have a very understanding
wife a very supportive family
friends who encouraged me and you know
always support the things that I'm doing
but I don't have people who are pushing
me to do better you know I don't have
people who say you know what what you're
doing is great but you should be out
here like you could be making these
adjustments and playing a bigger game
you can have a bigger impact and so I
needed more of that in my life
and so my solution defining it was was
the videos was I want to hang her on
Elon Musk and I want to hang around
Steve Jobs don't want to hang around
Warren Buffett I want to hang around
these people we're thinking on a bigger
scale because the more you do that the
more you ingest this content the more
you're gonna think like them the more
you're gonna act like them the more
you're gonna pick these pieces to not
only just be like them but to be the
best version of you I think what most
people do is we we try to escape a life
that we don't like we watch Big Brother
on TV we watch these reality shows we
like laughing at somebody else's faults
and mistakes we're constantly you know
looking at Facebook and Instagram and
looking at the negativity of people you
know hating each other we like watching
fail videos you know we like escaping
our life there's something about our
life that we don't like and so we want
to escape it why do people want to go on
vacations all the time well it's not
because they actually want to go there
it's more they want to escape a life
that they don't like and there's nothing
wrong with traveling it's a great time
that get experiences meet new people
think outside the box but it shouldn't
just be an escape from a life that you
don't like and that's where most people
spend their time
use that time instead to do the
uncomfortable thing to grow to build
muscle right to challenge yourself to
look towards a life that you want to
live by surrounding yourself with the
people who push you to think differently
to do the uncomfortable things to grow
to go outside your comfort zone right to
do that scary thing that you want to do
that you think is too bold too bad too
big Who am I to go off and do that you
know the more you spend time around
these successful people the bolder
you're going to be the more confidence
you're gonna have and the bigger impact
you're gonna be able to go out and
create and so it's one of the
foundational reasons why I still do
these YouTube videos why I love it so
much why I'm still invested so much into
the regular creation of this content
because it's awesome that it helps you
it helps me like I need it I need the
push I need Elon Musk kicking my butt I
need to watch I suffer realize you know
what I'm still playing small I'm working
harder than most of the people that I
know and I need to be doing more you
know I need to be thinking on a bigger
scale I need to have greater ambitions
because I believe if you have the
ability then you have the responsibility
if you can then you must and I know that
I can and I'm not doing enough and I
know that you can you're not doing
enough either and so the people that you
surround yourself are really important
yes the people in your life yes your
spouse is super important yes the
friends that you choose to surround
yourself with some people you may not
have an option you know your family may
not be supportive you can limit exposure
but you may not have an option they're
still your family you haven't chosen
them but the rest of your time like
you're not spending 24/7 with your
family the rest of the time you get to
choose and are you choosing to just
escape a life that you don't like and
watching content that numbs your mind
what are you choosing to move in a
forward direction make your life better
you consume content that makes you want
to be a better version of you and having
a bigger impact on the world
so the question of the date today is I'm
curious what's the one thing in your
environment if it's a regular video
series that you watch if it's a friend
that pushes you like what's the one
thing in your environment that is
consistently pushing you to be that
better version of you I'd love to see
what your answers are I think it could
inspire a lot of people as well please
leave it down in the comments below I
also want to give a quick shout out to
norman James Norman thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book here
one word I really really appreciate the
support and I hope you enjoyed the read
so thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of Enter
but does that look like your group no it
doesn't look like your group I mean in
no way shape man or a form you know
maybe if we had a bunch of bunny rabbits
running there or it's unbelievable but
again you are who you hanging around
with you know and as Oprah Winfrey says
and which I talk about a lot is that you
want people with a like mind and that
are better than you smarter than you
more intelligent than you to get on your
bus
and don't be so concerned about what
you're gonna do with those people but
you want to you know the joint brain is
you know there's nothing the joint brain
collective brain or brains can't
overcome and I give the example of the
atomic bomb Manhattan Project and they
were put together and they were told we
need we need to develop a weapon of mass
destruction which they didn't call it
that back in those days in the middle
40s to end the war in the Pacific and
they did they didn't know if I was
implode or explode but they did but if
you're if your team doesn't look like
that then you should I won't say you
should give serious thought you should
just change the most important is what I
like to call surround yourself with with
your dream team hmm
I called Josh Altman's dream team and it
consists of of a good amount of support
from people that I trust value their
opinion and who I surround myself with I
always say that you are the average of
five people that you surround yourselves
with right you ever hear that before
yeah I totally Jim Rome just made that
up kind of so I think it's super
important to do that so in real estate
for example I have the best mortgage
broker who's available 24/7 for me and
we've worked our way up in the business
together I have you know everybody from
the best title guy and escrow guy and
and all that so I surround myself with
this team of of people who I can trust
and they can guide me in the right
directions of whatever I do so that's
one way obviously in any business is
just surround yourself
with some wit with people who support
you observe your environment at work at
school at home I'm asking you to look at
the people around you purposefully and
intentionally invite people into your
life who don't look like you don't think
like you don't act like you don't come
from where you come from and you might
find that they will challenge your
assumptions and make you grow as a
person you might get powerful new
insights from these individuals if you
have to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon they
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details